my name is Eduardo links Henrique I'm
the co-founder of a company called Mali
now I am the CEO of wavy my career
before SCP was mostly about being an
entrepreneur full of dreams
always thinking big but I was missing a
framework and knowledge and techniques
to deal with the growth of my company
what we learned at ICP is how can I be
much better how can I just rub my
current business to create something 10
20 50 times bigger as if he brought to
me not only the framework the books the
theories but also the networking with
colleagues also a networking of
professors and specialists in certain
areas that helps me a lot when I have a
challenge or I need to build a new plan
and your area a new company sometimes
being a CEO or being an entrepreneur
it's it's a very lonely experience
having access to a couple of friends
that are in the same level that you are
and sometimes feel the same way that you
feel you can give a call you can ask for
advice
[Music]
if you are thinking about coming to SCP
it's it's important for you to be ready
to change to change and have a higher
impact in your life higher impact in
your company higher packing in the world
because this is absolutely
transformational